I thought that shame had some scenes
this movie has some scenes also and
there there better blue is the warmest
color won the Golden Palm at the Cannes
Film Festival that's kind of like the
best picture of the Cannes Film Festival
and it was the first time in history
that that award was actually given to
the actresses that starred in the film
as well which is a humongous achievement
thus I was very excited to check out
this movie it just opened in Cleveland
and arthouse cinema I went up there I
watched this three hour-long romance
movie and Here I am to talk about it
blue is the warmest color as a French
film it's all subtitled and it's about
these two girls who sort of discover
love with each other one of the girls is
younger than the other and she's just
kind of realizing that she has feelings
for other women this girl's name is
Adele and since the film starts with her
in high school it really explores the
repercussions of what it would be like
to want to come out as gay in school at
that time in France and what that could
do to your social status and the friends
you've already have and when she meets
this girl with blue hair named Emma she
gets very infatuated with her strikes up
a relationship with her and then the
film spans a long time I mean years and
the way the film decides to tell this
story is very unconventional it doesn't
say like 10 years later or five years
later you get to kind of figure out that
time has passed as characters hairstyles
have changed in living situations and
job situations and I really like that
because this is the first very small
French film that I've ever actually
considered to be an epic it's like an
epic romance really but it's very small
very low-budget but it spans a long
period of time and you really get
emotionally invested in this person's
life because you feel a lot for Adele
because you've seen her through high
school and all through this time in her
life and into the future and you get to
see her go through virtually every
emotional up-and-down you could go
through as a person and I was really
blown away by the statements this movie
makes about society about art about how
your social status affects the way you
are with other people and affects
relationships it has a lot to say about
that and it's a very impressive movie
while also being incredibly erotic
absurd like the scenes in this
movie are crazy I don't want to just
talk about these scenes throughout this
entire review but for goodness sakes I
mean they're pretty long and they look
ton simulated but apparently they were
simulated it's funny because something
that happened to me when I saw shame in
theaters happened to me when I saw this
movie in theaters there was an older man
both times at the back of the theater
and every once in a while I'd hear this
mmm I'm not even kidding it's completely
true according to the IMDB trivia they
shot over 800 hours for this movie this
director whose name I cannot pronounce
at all that's absurd
they had so much footage for this movie
and you can really tell that because
there are scenes in this film where yeah
you're watching this movie it's three
hours and there are times when you're
like does this really have to be here
does this have to be here can we maybe
skip this scene because he definitely
let scenes go on a lot longer than your
average filmmaker would there's an
impressive aspect of that but there's
also an aspect of that where you're like
okay maybe this could be cut down a
little bit but the film has a lot to say
like I said about social statuses
societies different societies of people
and art and one of the things this movie
definitely explores is how two people of
different social statuses operates and
how that can affect a relationship and
the film definitely has a lot of
discussions where it shows people just
talking about their ideas of art and you
can totally be like this is just a
hipster movie or this is a high-class
French porn movie and I can completely
understand why you'd say that in our
aspects of this movie where I would
completely agree with you as well but
there's something so real and raw about
this relationship that takes it beyond
the pornography route because
pornography is fake this movie felt real
and the relationship felt real there
were time for this movie war I actually
felt violated as in most romance films
there were moments where the couples not
doing too hot and you feel like their
relationships in trouble during those
moments I legitimately felt bad inside
and that's some serious filmmaking and
writing and acting because these
actresses are both oscar-worthy but they
probably won't be because of the film's
lurid content as usual Thank You Academy
a killer Joe shame didn't care about it
probably care about this movie either it
deserves to actress nominations without
a doubt in my opinion the film has
terrific things to say about the way
people can discover their own sexuality
or their first love
it has a really well-rounded view of it
all it's not just let's just film some
lesbians and make it all hot because
people have said that they're like well
there's a male director and he took a
pornography perspective when you made
this movie there are scenes in male gay
bars as well it's not a film that just
focuses on it to try to make it sexy it
has a very well-rounded view of people
who discover that that is the type of
life they would like to lead and it
tells a very genuine story of people
like that and it's very emotionally
touching blue is the warmest color is a
long movie it's not easy to watch
sometimes there are some great scenes in
it and I'm not just talking about what
you think I'm talking about there are
some truly emotionally impactful scenes
in this movie that definitely had my
heart in a place that felt wrong like it
just there were parts of this movie that
really got under my skin to the point
where I felt so much like these
characters were real and that's a
testament to great writing directing and
acting I'm gonna give blue is the
warmest color and a I do think it is one
of the best foreign films I've seen this
year I really like the hunt
also with Mads Mikkelsen but this is
definitely a good one I would suggest
checking this out if you can I know it's
nc-17 and not all my viewers can
technically go to the theater and see
this not gonna recommend anyone that
under 18 see it but I also cannot
control you if you decide to watch it so
do what you want it's not my you are
your own person and I guess my question
to you would be what is your favorite
film that you have seen that is nc-17
guys thanks as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck Benoist
Oh